Does India’s oldest political dynasty face
oblivion?
A defeat in the crucial southern state of
Karnataka suggests that it’s possible.
The Nehru-Gandhi dynasty has stayed close
to, or at the summit of, Indian politics for
nearly 100 years.
But for the 47-year-old Gandhi—the son,
grandson, and great-grandson of prime ministers—the
path to power appears increasingly steep.
Over the past eight years, battered by a series
of electoral defeats, Gandhi has plunged in
the public imagination from prime minister-in-waiting
to shaky underdog.
Each defeat amplifies questions about his
inherited privilege, warmed-over policy agenda,
and lack of political skills.
The loss in Karnataka will also hurt Congress’s
ability to raise funds.
In Prime Minister Narendra Modi and his well-oiled
Bharatiya Janata Party, Mr. Gandhi faces a
foe both popular and ruthless.
As the 2019 general election approaches, Congress
must grapple with arguably its greatest challenge
since Indian independence seven decades ago.
The big question about the party is no longer
“Will it reclaim power?”, but “Will it survive?"
What do you think about Rahul Gandhi's political future?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.